alors c'est jean yves duclos candidat
dans la circonscription de québec pour
le parti libéral du canada qui était
avec nous ce soir bonsoir monsieur
duclos
bonjour si fillon reçoit tous ceux qui
nous écoutent la plateforme des
conservateurs qui a été diffusé et deux
semaines portent beaucoup sur le soutien
aux pme aux entreprises on axe beaucoup
vers le soutien aux entreprises pour
stimuler l'économie vous faites moins ça
vous miser davantage sur l'immobilier la
santé les programmes sociaux les années
pourquoi cette stratégie
je vous dirais que ce trio a très bien
résumé la situation un plan qui est
responsable
un plan qui est prudent et un plan qui
est transparent monsieur fillion temps
d'aller chercher la confiance des
électeurs le 20 septembre prochain pour
que les gens aient confiance il faut que
les partis soient transparents comme l'a
très bien dit on est le seul parti à
robin de façon transparente et chiffré
qui taxe est effectivement sur les
entreprises on est des secteurs comme
dans ma circonscription
tiens donc beaucoup a lâché tourisme
hébergement et démentielles culture il
ya des travailleurs aussi qui ont encore
la difficulté à se trouver un emploi on
veut devant les accompagner par la
formation voire la technologie et donc
c'est une combinaison ou faire en sorte
qu'on puisse continuer à sortir fort et
uni cette crise vous parler de
responsabilités est ce qu'il est
responsable d'ajouter
336 milliards de dollars de déficit
supplémentaire en 5 1 sans même donner
en plus de cibles de retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire
mais vous l'avez déjà entendu à votre
votre analyse le dis on était déjà en
2021 2022 le déficit a chuté de moitié
va chuter de moitié à nouveau l'année
prochaine doit se retrouver autour de 35
milliards dans trois ans le rapport de
la dette
par rapport au produit intérieur but que
vous citez souvent monsieur fillon comme
étant le meilleur éducateur oui la santé
comme d'ailleurs j'essaie de comprendre
parce qu'il ya un petit peu de
croissance économique supplémentaire il
ya un peu de taxes supplémentaires sur
les banques et les compagnies
d'assurance mais comment votre date va
baisser beaucoup plus ce 14 août un
budget
pour trois raisons la première c'est
effectivement on investit la deuxième
c'est que on va chercher des rentes de
revenus on impose les grandes banques
des grandes institutions financières
chercher plus d'argent dans les poches
des contribuables d'entre eux qui se
sont très bien débrouillés au cours des
derniers mois et qui compliquait star
très bien et la troisième chose ce que
notre économie est présentement dans le
monde au sein des pays du g7 du g20
l'économique une des économies
certainement qu'ils retrouvent le plein
emploi le plus rapidement possible peau
pourquoi aussi parce qu'on à protéger
notre tissu social et que donner durant
la crise on était 92 pour ça du retour
des emplois perdus contre contre 75% ou
sur les frontières mais on dirait que
c'est une pensée magique la baisse de la
dette là on joue avec les chefs g7
j'essaie vraiment de comprendre comment
on peut aller chercher autant de points
de pourcentage de baisse d'endettement
mais mes passions l'étude allez vous
dire que c'est une relation basée sur
les estimations indépendantes est très
récente du directeur parlementaire du
budget c'était juste une dizaine de
jours que son rapport a été déposé c'est
là dessus que les projections
économiques sont rasés concernant qu'on
saura ça sexy mois comme l'asie où on ne
sait pas le groupe peuvent rendre le
registre est à dire que le directeur
parlementaire du budget a produit un
rapport avant le début de la campagne
électorale pour mettre à jour les
données vous dites dans la plate forme
que vous avez consulté directeur
parlementaire soumis à son examen
bon nombre de nos initiatives les plus
importantes et les plus complexes
lichens
non aux des plus importantes que je
pourrais vous faire aller c'est
évidemment les eaux des plus parmi les
plus importantes ont été soumises à la
banque alimentaire de vg pour lui
faciliter son travail
d'ailleurs un extrait ex directeur
parlementaire du budget que vous
connaissez bien monsieur pêche va sortir
ou sortir quelques instants je crois
pour dire qu'il avait pris connaissance
de notre plateforme et qui pouvaient
dire que sur tous les critères qu'il
avait utilisé notre plateforme était
solide donc une réponse rapide parce
qu'on a fourni à tous les ans tous les
gens aient conclu le parlementaire du
budget des informations transferts
nécessaires pour porter un jugement le
plan de 100 milliards 108 milliards de
mme adam freeland plan de relance dont
elle parlait d'un budget est-ce que
c'est dans la plateforme je le vois pas
tout est inclus dans la ligne si vous
regardez en temps c'est mal année un
budget de il ya délégué dictionnaire
pour tenir compte des annonces des
investissements additionnels que la
plateforme vécu mais dans le budget 2021
900 milliards n'était pas intégrée dans
la dette c'était comme une case à part
qui était à développer je me demande si
le plan de relance et dans votre
plateforme votre cadre financier
aujourd'hui
peinture tous y compris les nouveaux
investissements annoncés dans la
plateforme et d'anciens et nouveaux
investissements les nouveaux revenus
aussi con alors que l'on recherchait
leur ai parlé évidemment la taxation des
banques et des citoyens les conduire des
plus riches mais aussi une taxation des
géants du web évidemment que vous savez
qu'ils sont liés or tout cela est inclus
dans la place votre stratégie sur le
logement a pour but de faciliter l'accès
à la propriété
c'est vrai que c'est très difficile pour
les jeunes aujourd'hui de s'acheter une
propriété compte tenu de la hausse des
prix des maisons est ce que vous ne
craignez pas en même temps que ça vient
de favoriser l'endettement grandissant
qui est quand même une préoccupation de
la banque du canada
tout est fait il faut effectivement
protéger les jeunes en trop qui comme
vous dites et c'est vrai la masa
construction qui ont de plus en plus de
difficultés à se trouver une première
propriété donc c'est pour ça que quand
on dépend libre d'impôt de 40 et de
l'art et a été annoncée avec mise en
place on travaille aussi sur l'offre de
logement parce que mon sucrière de
l'économie ça dépend de l'offre est
tellement dans la situation des puits et
le résultat sur l'endettement on
travaille aussi sur les droits parce que
marche immobilier de marché en
surchauffe
dans lequel le rapport de force n'est
pas égale entre les acheteurs et les
vendeurs il ya entre autres une pression
des acheteurs étrangers qui nuit au
marché immobilier et qui vit par
conséquent des capacités des gens ne se
procurait une première propriété dernier
point beaucoup d'annoncés sur la santé
la santé mentale les soins de longue
durée mais pas de transferts fédéraux en
santé supplémentaires pas d'engagement
pas d'engagement cette matière ce qui
est la demande de françois legault et
des provinces au canada pourquoi vous
n'allez pas là mais 2e ce qui est
annoncé c'est effectivement dessus des
transferts ciblée sur la base des
priorités des gouvernements des
provinces de trentaine de rencontres
avec les provinces et territoires au
cours des pandémies il connaît très bien
ils connaissent très bien les pirates et
les provinces mais on est aujourd'hui
monsieur toujours répété qu'il va y
avoir aussi une discussion importante à
avoir sur les transferts de plus long
terme et cette discussion là qu'on s'est
tous est importante sur la base à la
fois de france retrouvé 9 a créé aussi
de ce qu'on connaissait déjà la
fragilité notre système de soins dont
c'est à venir mais on ne saura pas avant
de voter autrement dit
mais déjà les gens service que je rends
la pandémie on était là pour les
provinces noir 30 milliards en gros les
infrastructures surtout en santé mais on
reste là aussi immédiatement et s'est
lancé dans la plate forme et on va aussi
être la plus tard dans les prochains
mois on l'espère bien selon ce que les
canadiens décideront le 20 septembre
pour avoir la de plus long terme avec
les provinces et territoires merci
michel duclos d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir
merci beaucoup bonsoir à tout moment
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi